so on yesterday the President of the
United States when asked about why he
was silent about the fallen soldiers the
four soldiers who died in Niger Donald
Trump had this to say we're gonna play
the video for you the traditional way if
you look at President Obama and other
presidents most of them didn't make also
a lot of them didn't make calls I like
to call when it's appropriate when I
think I'm able to do it well this may
come as a shock to you but Donald Trump
was lying here Donald Trump was making a
statement that was incorrect
NBC News was reporting there's a quote I
want to bring up on your screen
a White House former Obama White House
official said that President president
Trump's claim is wrong President Obama
engaged families of the Fallen and
wounded warriors throughout his
presidency through calls letters visits
to section 60 at Arlington visits to
Walter Reed visits to Dover and regular
meetings with gold star families at the
White House and across the country now
when I heard the clip yesterday I knew
Donald Trump was wrong
simply because he was talking off the
cuff tried to make an assertion to try
to muddy the waters and and this is what
he does with his language Donald Trump
is very intentional with his
ossification of his language he's trying
to create a word salad to get something
over on America and he doesn't realize
that he's no longer in the boardroom
where he could just talk and actually
say anything he wants without America
fact-checking him and so it only took a
few hours for people to come out and to
fact-check him when a a woman who lost
her brother in Iraq she called him out
on Twitter saying the george w bush he
actually reached out to his but her
family after after he her brother was
killed and so i mean case after case
after case we see that donald trump is a
liar and there's actually no need for it
i think that's the biggest thing here
it's not the not the fact that he's a
liar but he lies about things that
there's no reason to lie
whatsoever who cares that you have not
that any other whatever any other
administration may or may not have done
that is not a defense for you all
Donald Trump had to say in this case was
we've written letters and I'm going to
make calls and that would be it but like
a child this is really a childish tactic
this is something that I catch my son
doing he tries to adjust the truth ever
so slightly to get out of trouble
because he knows damn well Donald Trump
knows that he did not do anything to
recognize the four soldiers who died the
other part of this is not only is it
completely unnecessary and not only is
it him trying to adjust the truth to get
out of trouble but it also demonstrates
the level of hypocrisy from the
Republican Party does anyone remember
what happened after Benghazi the the
investigations the accusations of dawn
of President Obama and Secretary of
State Clinton Hillary Clinton not caring
about about the soldiers the the
diplomat that was killed
does anybody recall that they gave
President Obama and Hillary Clinton hell
four years because of their accusation
that the President of the United States
and the Secretary of State specifically
did not care enough about American
soldiers and yet we have complete and
utter silence from the Republican Party
the same people who convened countless
hearings and investigations into
Benghazi but what do we know about what
happened after Benghazi a minimum we
know this President Obama and Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton together showed
up to to welcome home the remains of all
those people who were killed in Benghazi
they were there where was Donald Trump
he was at a golf course and not only was
he in a golf course but not only did was
he not there when their bodies returned
but he had not sent a letter or made a
phone call at the time he was asked the
question on yesterday and so what do you
do when you are a child and you have not
done your homework well you try to
obfuscate you try to wiggle your way out
or you tried to mix words together to
convince people in that moment but what
he doesn't realize Donald Trump doesn't
understand is that this is no longer the
environment in which you can get away
with that but he continues to try he
continues to try without fail he's gonna
try
over and over and over again and this
time he's been called on the carpet
not only by by reporters he's been
called on the carpet by family members
of the Fallen who President Obama and
President Bush visited he's been called
out the only people who have not called
out Donald Trump mind you the only
people who have not called out Donald
Trump our Republicans they are the only
people who have not called him out and
that's because they are stuck in between
having a president who is a complete
[ __ ] and a buffoon and a complete
embarrassment and trying to stay loyal
to their party but I'm sorry at some
point you have to just just take it on
the chin and say it it may be a betrayal
of our party but we can no longer stand
by the cretan that is Donald Trump